hello everyone we are back at Women in
Technology international we are now
sitting down with dr. Santosh curry neck
good morning hello good morning thank
you for coming on to the show thank you
for having me it's been a real pleasure
yes I'm really happy that you won your
award last night thank you so much means
a lot and you're much deserving of it so
you are a professor at the Rochester
Institute of Technology yes and a
professor of Electrical &
microelectronic engineering that's true
yes yes and a PhD preview in New Delhi
yes I did my PhD in physics from
University of Delhi in India and now my
research is sort of at the intersection
of physics Electrical Engineering and
material science so when we combine all
the three disciplines we talk about
micro electronics so that's what I teach
and that's what I do my research on
there are a number of devices that I'm
working on they go in your micro
circuits and also they go on your
rooftop that means I'm working on solar
cells to make their efficiency higher so
that we can make energy cheaper in the
future more renewable so that's the area
I work in teach material science physics
and electrical engineering electrical
engineering give us the ability to have
chips inside of our phones and computers
that make it process data very quickly
efficiently and then the efficiencies
are going smaller and smaller in terms
of is it that both the distance between
transistors exactly that's what you are
saying very very very right so basically
when you look at any electronic circuit
let's say you open the back side of your
computer desk you see lots of wires
going around right so when your chip
becomes such a big huge circuit so there
lot of wires so we put them all in a
very small volume so a microchip is
basically a conductivity architecture of
materials we put lots of materials we
change their conductivity so sorry
silicon we dope it to make a p-type and
type and make all kinds of circuits then
we connect the circuit with wires all in
a volume as small as less
one micron cube and the distance between
each transistor these days is of the
order of nanometers so you can imagine
now just imagine a skyscraper with the
smallest room of the size of ten
nanometer so you have billions of
transistors in one chip how do we make
them it's not magic they are made out of
periodic table we are using silicon
phosphorus boron gallium arsenic copper
tantalum tungsten so we take all these
materials engineer them to make this
device which is a really a marvel of
modern technology what percentage is it
silicon the substrate is silicon
basically the starting substrate at the
moment is silicon because this is the
most predominant element second most
predominant element on earth crust it
has a right bandgap and we can make big
crystals out of it it has a diamond
structure just like diamond structure
and substrate is silicon but we only use
the top half a micron part of the
substrate most of the devices go on top
of it so silicon is basically like steel
for automobiles and aluminium for
Aeronautics but there's lot more
materials on top of it so we are also
putting novel materials on top of
silicon to improve the efficiency of the
circuits but that's a constant
innovation in struggle that's going on
so that's what I work on different
materials different configurations and
different circuits different ways of
storing memory in the device so that
your memory stays longer and you can put
denser memory into your chips because
data is expanding you have a lot of
information you want to store and that
means you have to make your memory cells
very small and they should last long so
that you don't erase your memory when
the power is turned off
we call it non-volatile memory so we are
working on some of those areas and we
also are inspired by nature look at
brain how human brain stored memory you
know we still remember our childhood
memories how do we store it so we are
trying to mimic the
we can make computers the way brain
things we can also make devices in such
a way so that's the areas that I work
with my students with my collaborators
all because the field is become so
complicated that one person alone cannot
do everything you need expertise from
different segments so I work with
computer engineers I work with material
scientists work with product developers
so you have to work together to think of
a product and we start doing research on
it
that's what do that them I really want
to connect you to Ahmed Amer who we've
had on the show who's at Santa Clara
University who was doing data and memory
stores yes because he was teaching us
about if we transition our thinking
process from this is our data to this is
our memory it's family
then then that changes our relationship
to all of this data exists our memories
Andy
also what you said earlier about silicon
being two chips what steel is two
automobiles and what aluminum is the
planes yes I thought that's really thank
you yeah it's very good it's very
relatable analogy yeah we have seen more
and more materials in our automobiles we
have the carbon nanotubes carbons in
many other alloys are showing up but
there's always something based we can
augment more right so we can always bind
more substitutes to improve the
efficiencies but some things becomes
sort of standardized because they have
the properties that we need silicon has
a band gap of 1.1 2 electron volt which
makes it always remains in a stable
state at the terrestrial temperatures
like you can go to cold temperatures you
can go to hot temperatures its
performance remains good so it's almost
suited for 380 Kelvin on earth so but if
you go to automotive arena where the
temperatures are say 800 degrees
centigrade or so then silicon may not
work at those temperatures so then we
worked with silicon carbide another
semiconductor that can withstand high
temperatures is this the same silicon
that goes into our nonstick cooking pans
very flexible ones no that's a silicone
I think they use a different word for
that that's some sort of a polymer but
that's silicone so silicone versus
silicon silicon is an element group is
an element silicon is what is that it's
a kind of polymer it's a polymer that's
what I understand I'm not perfect I'm
not this is good now I have to go learn
about it so silicon is power silicon is
the element and then you said silicon is
ideal for chips because of its is it
conductivity yes it has a it's a semi
conductor so pure silicon has higher
resistivity is it between insulator and
metal but when you dope it when you put
some sort of some parts per million or
phosphorus or boron into it you can make
it conducting so since you can make it
conducting parts per million of boron or
phosphorus or arsenic yes arsenic so any
of these Justin's very small enables
silicon to start yes being good for
conductor yes then it becomes a
conductor of p-type or n-type then you
can make diodes PN Junction you can make
transistors PNP or NPN or you can make
MOSFETs so then you can make switches
whence we make switches you make digital
circuits once you made the circus you
can make logic gates and that's how
these circuits development okay so okay
so once you make the transistors then
you can make a logic gate yes okay and
then that would be the electricity
flowing to one of these gates and the
gate being opened or closed yes and then
that being how it processes 0 or 1 0 or
1 and then there's a billion or trillion
of these gazer there billions of that 30
billion in a modern chip somebody
billion gates
yes modern ship yes and it's all in this
size they all may be 1 centimeter by 1
centimeter of area 1 centimeter by 1
centimeter
oh maybe oh maybe some some chips are
slightly bigger footprint and the height
may be just few microns so we put so
much big circuits in the small volume so
that means that most of these
development has happened because of the
way that we make these devices are they
made they made with photolithography
printing so all the advances in optics
and imaging has helped us make these
devices so we basically make layer by
layer by layer structure just imagine
this room we have a rug at the bottom
and we have walls and we have wires so
we will put first layer then pad on it
then put second layer then pad on it
then third layer pattern in such a way
that forms that multi-level structure
how do you do that at the nanometer
level that's the key nanometer level
means we need to have optics that can
shrink the sizes through that small so
resolution has to be very good so
there's a lot of development on
photolithography that mean lenses and
the wavelength of light that is used to
create those structures so a lot of
research is on how do we pattern these
materials so patterning means
photographic printing and then itching
and depositing and etching
depositing edging deposit edge so you
have to do that at nano scales see okay
see you edge into the silicon yes then
you deposit the transistor yes what we
do is we we start with silicon wafer and
we dope it in the regions we want to
dope which are called the source and the
drain of the transistor so we
selectively dope it then we put gate
oxide in gate metal so that means you
have to put oxide where you want you
want to put metal where you want so that
means you have to have the patterning
system in place and then keep going and
keep aligning it well and then start
wiring it to the back end so it's a very
very elaborate process so you need very
modern fabs to do that so most of the
current wraps that we have they are
distributed all across the world and
typically the investment in modern fab
is about 10 billion dollars so and you
use wafers of the size of 300
millimetres about Pisa sized wafers so
we take a pizza sized wafer and we start
making the chips then we cut the chips
out from the wafer once they are made
then you put it in a package then
package is put on your device
from from the pizza wafer that's where
the tip side chips are made and there's
a couple thousand of these it's a wafers
in a fab oh yes they run 24/7 on almost
automated fabs you won't see a human
being they are automated in such a way
that they go from one step to another
step in a robotic way the wafers go from
one footprint to the other footprint you
deposit earlier you you print it you
etch it you deposit you print an edge it
just passes it along yes and all in the
size of very like this this small very
yes each each die on a wafer is a chip
so if you just imagine a pizza size and
maybe chip is of the size of your
pepperoni pepperoni yeah something like
that
so we cut it and we dices cut it and
then we package it and that goes to
circuits yeah Wow so this chip is become
very exotic these days they are we make
many chips be sometimes stack them up
and three three dimensional integration
it's like big cities you know when it
become crowded you grow up yeah so these
chips are so dense now we started to
build in 3d integration so so that they
can have more functionality at a small
footprint print yes yeah ten billion
dollars for a fab okay you were teaching
me about this earlier you're saying that
the the fabs you out like to ask your
students about what makes it what makes
countries able to have fabs yes so ten
billion dollars is a lot of money it's a
lot of money it's gonna be a GDP of some
nations it's a very high investment
because technology is so advanced it
requires so many resources and I believe
that the place where you can have a good
source of electricity cheaper source of
electricity more access to water and
transportation because you have to move
all this stuff to that particular place
so you need all those resources to build
a fab and a lot of investment goes into
it the most important is even though I
said they are mostly robotic you know
they're automated but still we need
workforce because you put so much
investment into these machines
so we needs very scientifically trained
workforce for these to work in these so
that is our mission and I teach
microelectronic engineering we catch
students from all over the globe
and they learn and I someday I feel that
they will go back to wherever they like
to go back and create such fabs in the
future because we will be needing them
we will yes yes and we'll be moving into
an era of lots and lots of devices yes
future that are gonna need micro
electronics engineers and and especially
them coming going back and stimulating
their countries with fab fabrication
Center plants so now question about as
we go into the the the even smaller the
quantum computing era as we go past the
nanometer even further down what what is
it good what is about to be occurring at
in micro electronics at that quantum
level and that's a very good question we
constantly think about it we call it
Musleh that we are making devices shrink
every technology node is shrinking more
and more and we already reached about 10
nanometer node and after that we do feel
that there are some bottleneck posed by
physics you know every electron has a de
Broglie wavelength so once you reach the
wavelength of the electron you are
limited so therefore a a beyond three
nanometer we will feel that challenge
challenge so there are a lot of new ways
of looking into it industry and experts
are looking at quantum computing where
we can go to wave function overlap of
single atom and that's the era that is
physicists are being accept constantly
exploring new ways of computing
information for the future but as I say
that 3d integration is another way of
densifying your computer chip capability
if we can't go further in the XY plane
we will go up in the Z plane so that's
those are the trends we are seeing this
is so crazy because quantum computing is
also affecting encryption as well which
is going to be crazy especially with
this proliferation of blockchain
technology in the security era any
mythography era now we have quantum
computing as well how are those going to
jazz and vibe how are we actually going
to get down to the past the three
nanometer level there wasn't you said it
was a problem with the electron right
that yes I mean we are relying on the
electron motion in our digital switches
so that means that if they if you're
confining electron in such small volume
we may not be able to really distinguish
between 0 and 1 ah electrons in such
small voice yeah so the next area that
I'm still is area of mice for the
studies what we have to look into new
solutions to go further as your security
it's not my field but we really feel
that every time human beings are very
creative if they find a way to do
something they also find a way how to
make sure that it works so there's more
innovation in all in those areas in the
future yes and you've also done a lot of
work in photovoltaics now so so has
rochester's through technology
collaborating with the University of
Central Florida yes so since my
experience is on semiconductor devices
which are made up of semiconductor and
metal contacts and solar cell is also a
semiconductor device but it's not as
small as microchip it's a big cell it's
just one diode so it's just a big diode
what's the size of a photo compared to a
chip a typical cell these days you can
get about 156 millimeter by 156
millimeter mono crystalline silicon that
is available in the market and thickness
is about 150 to 200 micron so that's and
that's absorbing photons from the Sun
and then it's distributing that energy
to the grid
yes so the sunlight comes and solar cell
absorbs the sunlight
and the photons from the Sun they give
energy to electrons so electrons jump to
the conduction band and electrons and
holes get separated and when they
combine they gives the current to the
output circuit so that's all your
electricity is used
so typically solar cells are these days
in the market are close to 20% efficient
and in fact just two days and there was
announcement that a company has made 24%
silicon solar cell so we see it yes and
that means out of the 100 percent energy
from the Sun that comes and we keep 2014
yes and that's that is that the highest
so far highest on I would say that at
the manufacturing level if I make a nice
cell in my lab I can get higher
efficiency but there's a theoretical
limit to solar cell efficiency which was
posed by Shockley Kaiser initial theory
that there's a maximum efficiency you
can get so silicon can silicon can give
you about twenty eight percent maximum
efficiency theoretically but when you
actually make a device on a production
level you cannot reach threat achill so
quickly you know it takes time to get
manufacturing in place but to hit twenty
to twenty four percent is really
marvelous thing and we have seen that
happen whereas these days so we can put
all the solar tiles on our roof yes and
power the cars and so semiconductor
device it's a diode and but it's a big
device so I I've since I work on micro
electronics very small devices and solar
cell very big devices their challenges
in both now some to make something small
and to make something big without any
defect is also a challenge so so but we
work on it yeah it's interesting how
you're going from both micro electronics
with with computer chips and also with
solar cells and photovoltaics
and how those are larger on top of homes
and versus the smaller and phones yes so
it was natural for you to be interested
in both yes I think because
conductor physics combines the two it's
the same physics that's applies but the
the challenges are different and the
functionalities are different but you if
you understand semiconductor physics
then you can relate to you learn from
each other too so some concept we learn
from micro electronics we can apply to
solar cells some concept we apply to
solar cells we can use in micro
electronics so we learn from each other
that way yes yes I love that okay and
then do you think that solar is one one
of the or may be the most ideal form of
free and sustainable energy for us are
close to free or do you think maybe
nuclear fusion mastering that could be
even better for society yeah that's a
very good question I often think about
it and I think based on my experience
and my learning we need a energy
portfolio for every place not one form
of energy can solve all problems so I
can imagine solar panels running your
home electricity but if you when I see
the tractor-trailers on the road an
amount of energy they consume and when I
see the big power plants and energy use
in other areas we have to have a
balanced portfolio so I think it
peaceful use of nuclear energy is a very
good source of energy and if it's
developed in a reliable way we have wind
and we have other geothermal we have and
fossil fuel we have to minimize because
they are a resources are finite so we
are relying a lot on Sun but one thing
we must note that in order to convert
energy from one form to another say
chemical to mechanical mechanical to
chemical or mechanical to electrical we
always need matter so we need matter so
matter is also finite right so nothing
is infinite but we have to be very
careful in using all these resources to
be frugal with the use of energy and
that's what we should sustain we should
energy is a big resource I would say
that
what's the power we talk about is a very
big resource that is finite but we have
to value that and we have to find new
ways of making an energy portfolio
balanced portfolio yeah
there's I always wonder if we will get
to a point where we're me having
something doesn't preclude someone else
from having something so we can have a
society of ubiquity in all things I
always I always wonder about that but
matter is kind of the one of the big
variables in that equation what are your
thoughts on neuronal computing computing
with neurons that's not my field somehow
I'm not learned much about it but
there's something I should be looking
into okay interesting we have a friend
that is Asha - who's really starting to
to produce some interesting results in
that field and has testing yeah it's I
wonder how similar like if 86 billion
neurons could compute yeah that's what I
was mentioning to you about we have to
learn from how the brain works
you know how the synaptic connections
the brain works with your neural network
system whereas our digital computers
work on in one Neumann architecture so
there are two different architectures so
we can learn from each other and that's
why a lot of computing people are trying
to include neuromorphic computing yeah
in the algorithms and that's the area
that's going to grow I will make devices
they can make circuits yeah yeah yeah
and we will continue highlighting your
brilliance --is across the world so how
about we ask you just a couple questions
on the way out these are questions we
ask on the show a lot what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world that's a very good question and I
think the most beautiful thing is that
we have a brain that makes us explore
see enjoy the word
and we have the natural desire to be
curious and look at the nature look at
be on planet earth and try to solve our
problems as well as explore the universe
that's what I like yes I love that
answer
yeah we're so grateful to be able to
observe the cosmos and experience the
cosmos and solve these problems and work
together on this planet how about do you
think we're alone in the cosmos keeping
my math hat and my statistics head I
think that the probability that there is
only one life is very low I'm sure that
there are many planets many places which
have the conditions like Earth has or
conditions such that another form of
life can be sustained it's very much
possible someday we'll find them or
maybe they'll find us I look forward to
that day so much yes I want to be linked
up with the cosmic yes sisters and
brothers how about are we in a
simulation that's a very very
philosophic question and I know being a
material scientist if I can touch
something I can feel something I'm in
reality yes it's it's a question that
our show is named after because we like
the thought experiment around it because
it gives us a better understanding of
all the variables that have to go into
the world that we live in and into the
cosmic structure in the evolution yeah I
mean as a human body body is made up of
basic chemicals like carbon hydrogen
nitrogen oxygen and sodium potassium so
in other words our body is a
configuration so this configuration will
last for a certain amount of time and
after that these elements will dissipate
back in the universe so we have a finite
configuration that we can make an impact
to the word yes yes I'm downloading my
consciousness to the cloud as soon as
possible thank you nice to talk to you
thank you for coming on
the show we greatly appreciate it it's
because you're learning from you
everyone that's good questions that
makes me think even more and so thank
you very much we are very grateful to be
learning about all the incredible feats
of engineering and design that are
happening in both chips and
photovoltaics I mean this is a do both
tremendously important for the future of
our world so amazing thank you very much
everyone thank you for tuning in if you
had a good time make sure to share the
content with other people make sure to
go and create with this content don't
just watch but go and write go and make
a video yourself go and talk to more
people about it maybe start something in
one of these fields subscribe give us a
comment below with your thoughts also
join us on patreon so we can continue
coming to great places like women and
Technology International and
highlighting the brilliance here and we
will see you soon thank you thank you
thank you thank you
you